do you ever think about going at to Door
Dash any other job or was like this is
the question that every YouTuber never
wants to hear that you need to go apply
for a job somewhere mhm you this is no
longer a viable career option it's
honestly probably why a lot of people
when they're up will go into like
investing in creating their own product
or a brand abely something because you
kind of have to prepare yourself for
that day to come you got to be ready you
got toep for that day the thing is
there's got to be nothing worse than
being famous and bro imagine seeing
Jason Nash like you know baging
groceries not that that's not an
admirable job but imagine every day
people being like holy Jason Ash dude
you're bagging groceries what the what
are you doing here that would be rough
just non-stop everyday humiliation why
don't I get a real job okay you know
what just flavor that like that why
don't you get a real job uh I don't have
any skills that's the Boogie excuse
right